stupid
vladimir putin gave his go-ahead for the
start of the nuclear drills
joined by his belorussian counterpart
alexander lukashenko russia's president
chose saturday for these war games
usually they are held in october
the exercises involved russia's northern
and black sea fleets its air force as
well as soldiers on the ground
the kremlin says the missile systems all
able to launch nuclear warheads hit
their intended targets
the exercises of the strategic
deterrence forces are being carried on
in the course of which tasks of joint
management of nuclear weapons and
weapons of increased potential danger
will be worked over in the course of
committing an operation of strategic
attack forces
the russian-backed leaders of the
self-proclaimed republics of donetsk and
the hanks in ukraine's donbass region
announced the mass evacuation of women
and children on friday evening
in the southwest region of rostov
russian citizens continue to be bussed
in after being forced to leave their
homes in ukraine in the middle of the
night
the situation is terrible shooting has
been heard for three days we had to lock
their apartments and get dressed quickly
they said that in order for us not to
create any danger for ourselves we need
to evacuate i'm 75 years old i'm single
i don't have anyone to help
a state of emergency has been declared
in the rostov region
a shell was found to have landed in a
residential area a kilometer from the
ukrainian border
a second shell was found nearby which
russian officials say was fired by the
ukrainian army
with a window of diplomacy quickly
closing saturday's nuclear exercises
serve as yet another example of russia's
military strength but as the security
situation continues to rapidly
deteriorate on the borders with ukraine
many see the possibility of conflict as
increasingly inevitable
dorset jabari al jazeera moscow